[Musique]
bonjour heureux évidemment émue de vous
retrouver vraiment ça me touche beaucoup
ça me va droit au coeur votre accueil et
c'est le cas de le dire
alors merci je ne sais pas si pendant
cette longue et douloureuse parenthèse
vivement dimanche vous a manqué mais
vous m'avez beaucoup manqué depuis
mercredi la ministre de la culture est
hospitalisée elle a même dû être placé
sous oxygénothérapie renforcée c'est à
dire qu'elle bénéficie d'un apport
d'oxygène intensif qui permet d'éviter
l'intubation que je crois que l'an 2000
la médecine de l'an 2000 ce sera les
nouveaux virus et le sida est un nouveau
virus
je pense que cette association que nous
avons monté nous les artistes se
transformera en une fondation une
fondation des artistes pour combattre le
sida bien sûr mais aussi pour les
nouveaux virus
parce qu'en plus des 19 départements
soumis à des mesures de freinage
supplémentaires 25 autres ici en bleu
foncé où le virus circule de plus en
plus vite sont en vigilance renforcée
les bouches du rhône en font partie mais
à marseille
l'apéritif se prendront la rue en groupe
et souvent à plus de 6 ce qui est
interdit dans toute la france ça sert à
quoi qu'on parle de confinement regarder
c'est tout tant que vous n'avez pas un
membre de votre famille qui décède
on avait rien à [ __ ] une étude
américaine publiée fin janvier montrent
que le risque de s'infecter en touchant
une surface contaminée est inférieure à
0,05 pour cent en france une enquête sur
les soignants de cet hôpital lors de la
première vague souligne que la
transmission se fait d'abord par les
postillons où les aérosols exemple
pendant les réunions des voyageurs qui
dorment à même le sol des lits pour
enfants bricoler avec deux fauteuils
difficile à croire mais voici les
conditions dans lesquelles vivent depuis
un mois une vingtaine de ressortissants
algériens dans la zone internationale de
l'aéroport roissy charles de gaulle ont
révélé pour trois heures mais je peux
vous le dire nous avons eu raison de ne
pas confiner la france à la fin du mois
de janvier
parce qu'il n'y a pas eu d'explosion qui
était prévu par tous les modèles
donc je peux vous affirmer la cette fois
ci que je n'ai aucun mea culpa faire
n'ai aucun remords n'ai aucun constat
d'échec
nous avons eu raison de le faire au star
wars elle file à la file est un fils à
maman de traquer feu à l'est il est fan
factor elle fait la moue cette fille la
jeune fille une fois aimo scoring et les
fameux clichés athas nord riche il ils
arrivent par centaines à l'aéroport de
madrid de france et de toute l'europe
lisbonne strasbourg marseille ou encore
paris pour prendre un verre en terrasse
dans la capitale espagnole le couvre-feu
ne s'applique qu'à 23 heures les bars et
les restaurants sont ouverts
un retour à la vie d'avant pour ces
français on a quitté la france pour
venir à bas à madrid et c'est magnifique
depuis octobre l'institut pasteur étudie
les sources de contamination quand la
personne à l'origine d'une transmission
est connue elle est dans 42% des cas au
domicile 21 % dans la famille élargie
15% au travail et 11%
parmi les amis il faut se protéger donc
ça mais alors c'est à dire que six ou
sept là sont avec safe sex et for ever
c'est à dire pour toujours le safe sex
donc il faut toujours se protéger
il ya le caoutchouc que j'aime beaucoup
qui est une très belle matière comme dit
caroline loeb mais c'est celle que je
viens au ses chaussettes
oui se place ou dans le corps tout
dépend des professions
alors on se demande qui s'est passé hier
que la dengue aux yeux alors elle a
déménagé quand elle était étudiante on
en fit et le déménageur est encore là
huawei
qu'est ce qui a bien pu se passer il
avait monté l'armoire et pas deux
[Applaudissements]
vous nous parler de la grave wac qu'on
connaissait mieux chez nous en france
jusque là elle a pris le chien ça c'est
pas ça pas vous raconter ça ça m'a fait
rire parce que vous réussissez à glisser
dans le livre là j'étais vraiment
malheureux parce qu'en plus elle a pris
le chien non je dis pas qu'elle a pris
le chien des années que je n'ai pas vu
voilà gaga dément il ya compris des
détails ça peut être absurde futile
enfin vous vous aimez bien les chiens
donc vous pouvez comprendre ce que je
veux dire
concernant le chien il ya michel comme
votre chien aime l écart s on l'a
offerte à ppda messieurs pour savoir si
votre geste est déplacée et un truc tout
bête une question à se poser est ce que
vous le feriez si c'était la femme de
teddy riner
tout de suite on y voit plus clair de
réponse alors là soulvache de juin c'est
vrai que d'aliette et très macho
espagnol typique
non non non il n'ya que les hommes qui
ont du talent les femmes elles n'ont pas
de testicules donc elles n'ont pas de
talent comme ça moi quand on me dit ça
ça me révolte je faisais les beaux-arts
à l'époque alors terminé ce rallye dit
ouais on peut plus rien dire on peut
plus rien faire alors pierrot je te
confirme que si jamais tu galoche de
force comme tu l'as fait la femme de
teddy riner
tu ne pourras plus rien dire elle ne
pourra plus rien faire car dans des
brefs délais tu seras mourut ben j'ai
toujours pensé qu'à partir de 50 ans une
femme ne doit plus chanter non pourquoi
peut-être que maintenant c'est bah oui
avec la régie mais ces mondiaux faudra
quarante ans oui on peut encore
peut-être mais je trouve je pensais pas
aller au delà de 50 ans
il a nié fait warren a need you paint
ball online à need you baby tracy me
wanna line renaud s'est fait vacciner
avec cette légende
ne voilà repartis pour un siècle câline
un siècle et demi voire d un jour droit
nombreuses irm et scanner et au moment
rentrer pour la nième scanner sentant
deux infirmières qui s'était exemple
c'était un pantin et perdu 10 kilos qui
vit à sa copine ça grossit la td merci
beaucoup angus young à très bientôt
et voilà très bien les cornes
alors là fait les cornes voilà bonne
tourne à tous